[Música]
hoy he venido a hablaros de electrones y
fotones de física cuántica y de
garbanzas en la luna
os voy a contar que es la nanofotónica y
por qué ha sido tan importante y será
para todos nosotros y la culpa de que
esté hoy aquí la tiene esto si ya no
podemos vivir sin él
cada vez queremos saber más rápido tener
más contenido en nuestros móviles hablar
con alguien al otro lado del mundo de
manera inmediata escuchar nuestra música
ver vídeos de alta calidad y todo eso ha
sido posible gracias al gigantesco
avance de la electrónica y ya lo
entendemos nuestra vida sin todos estos
dispositivos que han cambiado nuestra
manera de relacionarnos nuestro ocio e
incluso nuestra manera de transmitir
ideas
la corriente eléctrica es un flujo de
electrones que circula por los cables de
todos los aparatos que cuando enchufamos
los hace funcionar el electrón es una
partícula pequeñísima subatómica de masa
ínfima y carga eléctrica negativa y
también está dentro de todos nuestros
dispositivos electrónicos las pantallas
los ordenadores
los relojes inteligentes
qué pensaríais si os dijera que toda esa
electrónica que conocéis podría
funcionar con luz en vez de con
corriente eléctrica que podríamos
olvidarnos de una vez por todas de esto
y tener todos nuestros documentos todos
nuestros discos todas nuestras fotos de
nuestra vida disponible en un solo clic
a la velocidad de la luz
la luz es una vieja conocida por todos
la experimentamos día a día a través de
nuestros ojos que son sensores de luz
además sabíais que los dos científicos
más conocidos de la historia
isaac newton y albert eisntein en
realidad dedicaron gran parte de su
investigación a explicarnos la
naturaleza de la luz
newton por ejemplo fue el que descubrió
que la luz blanca se descompone en los
colores del arcoíris al atravesar un
prisma y einstein einstein nos explicó
que la luz en realidad son cuantos o
paquetes de energía lo que hoy conocemos
como fotones
y por explicar el efecto fotoeléctrico
fue por lo que le dieron el premio nobel
y no por su famosa teoría de la
relatividad
la luz es en realidad a la vez onda y
partículas los fotones que no tienen ni
masa ni carga eléctrica al contrario que
el electrón entonces que son pues son
paquetes de energía
además hoy en día conocemos la luz muy
bien y la sabemos fabricar de las
maneras más extraordinarias por ejemplo
sabemos hacer diodos emisores de luz los
leds
o con puntos cuánticos hacemos
televisiones cooler
física cuántica en tu salón
la luz láser
qué pensaría y si dijera que podríamos
sustituir los electrones que hacen
funcionar nuestro teléfono móvil por las
partículas más veloces de la naturaleza
los fotones
tendríamos una tecnología muchísimo más
rápida de la actual con una fuente de
energía prácticamente inagotable además
os cuento que los circuitos con fotones
no se calientan sería una tecnología
mucho más eficiente tenemos además una
capacidad de miniaturización
extraordinaria podemos almacenar
millones de estos dispositivos fotónicos
en un solo chip
esto es
la nanofotónica la tecnología de la luz
a una escala cien mil veces más pequeña
que el tamaño de un solo cabello esto
que parece un sueño es a lo que dedico
de investigación
a los físicos nos encanta clasificar
todo
bueno lo hacemos un poco para sobrevivir
y la luz pues no se libra
la luz con he dicho es una onda
y la podemos clasificar por su tamaño
por su longitud de onda que es la
distancia que hay entre una cresta y la
siguiente que es muy larga pues tenemos
la luz microondas con la que calentamos
el café que es muy cortita tenemos los
rayos x que son muy energéticos penetran
en nuestra piel y los usamos para hacer
radiografías lo que ocurre es que
nuestros ojos solo ven un trocito la luz
visible a lo que comúnmente llamamos luz
pero la luz es mucho más
la luz recorre el vacío a una velocidad
constante de casi 300.000 kilómetros por
segundo
en este rat y nos da la vuelta al mundo
más de 70 veces
sin embargo cuando atraviesa otro medio
como el aire el agua o cualquier otro
material cambia su velocidad y también
su dirección su trayectoria a este
fenómeno se le denomina refracción y os
la voy a enseñar con un experimento muy
sencillo
mirad tengo aquí un jarrón lleno de
bolitas de hidrogel
estas bolitas se usan en jardinería como
sustituto del agua
con jarrones con plantas o con flores
porque porque son de un material súper
absorbente que absorbe tanta agua que
crece su tamaño hasta 150 veces por lo
que al final son prácticamente agua si
yo señaló mi jarrón por encima con una
placer solo vemos dónde se refleja en
las paredes del jarrón pero qué pasa si
ilumina dónde están las bolitas mira
nos gusta la física
a mí también
esto pasa porque la luz ha encontrado
una diferencia de camino entre el agua
que forman las bolitas y el aire que las
rodea
pero qué pasa si lleno mi jarrón de agua
pues lo más sorprendente es que parece
que las bolitas desaparecen pero no
siguen aquí
lo que ocurre es que ahora la luz no
encuentra diferencia de camino entre el
agua que forma las bolitas y el agua que
las rodea eso también se puede ver muy
bien con el láser
mira ahora sí que se ve la trayectoria
recta típica de este tipo de luz
qué pasa ahora si yo esté a recto lo
quisiera curvar
o que siguieron una trayectoria
determinada es eso posible
pues la respuesta es que si ya la podéis
imaginar
lo hacemos usando las propiedades la
refracción podemos atrapar la luz en
cables finos y flexibles como estos
esto es la fibra óptica la responsable
de que tengamos ese internet tan rápido
en nuestras casas
pero nosotros queremos hacer
dispositivos fotónicos
tan bonitos
como estos para que para hacer esos
dispositivos súper rápidos que podríamos
quizás integrar a algún día a nuestra
ropa en las paredes de nuestras casas o
quizás en nuestro cuerpo para detectar o
incluso curar enfermedades y esto cómo
lo hacemos
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
fabricar circuitos tan pequeños como el
tamaño de una sola célula esos son muy
pocas micras con componentes dentro del
tamaño de las bacterias unos cientos de
nanómetros
para ello trabajamos en un laboratorio
lleno de tecnologías super sofisticadas
que un día se desarrolló para poder
tener esto pero los fotónicos somos muy
listos y usamos esa misma tecnología un
poquito modificada para que nos salga
rápido y más barato
para que os hagáis una idea de lo
pequeños que son los circuitos que
fabricamos en el laboratorio nos tenemos
que vestir a sí
esa soy yo
se exige
bueno no nos vestimos así porque dentro
del laboratorio hay algo peligroso que
nos pueda contaminar sino porque no
queremos introducir en el laboratorio ni
una sola mota de polvo porque esa mota
de polvo en comparación con el tamaño de
mi circuito sería tan grande como si le
cayera a un meteorito encima
en un laboratorio donde hay menos de 10
motas de polvo por metro cúbico
tenemos un gran cañón de electrones que
hace la fabricación de los nano
circuitos
es el laboratorio además está separado
del resto del edificio y suspendido en
unas grandes vigas con unos muelles
enormes para el aislarlo de las de las
vibraciones que podemos fabricar
nosotros cuando caminamos por el
edificio los coches que pasan alrededor
o incluso el tranvía que pasa cerca es
el gran laboratorio se llama sala blanca
y es diez mil veces más limpia que un
quirófano
bueno pues ya tenemos nuestros circuitos
ahora tenemos que ser capaces de verlos
y eso lo hacemos porque tenemos los
microscopios más potentes del mundo los
microscopios electrónicos y los
microscopios de fuerzas atómicas veis
cómo tienen la culpa
y estos microscopios tienen un poder de
resolución equivalente a poder ver un
garbanzo en la superficie de la luna
todo esto a escala nanométrica os
recuerdo una escala con tamaños más
pequeños que un solo cabello
bien pues ya tenemos nuestros circuitos
los podemos ver ahora tenemos que ser
capaces de introducir la luz láser y
manipularla dentro del circuito
y esto como os podéis imaginar pues no
es tan fácil fijaos un circuito
electrónico es algo parecido a esto es
como una pequeña ciudad nosotros lo que
tenemos que hacer es sustituir cada
componente de un circuito electrónico
por uno fotónico y así construir nano
ciudades de luz de manera que
transmitiendo fotones podremos codificar
o transmitir información
y esto como ya he dicho es bastante
difícil una de las dificultades que nos
encontramos es que no podemos regular
ese tráfico de luz dentro de nuestro
nano circuito sin apagarlo por completo
no tenemos interruptores para los
fotones pero los físicos trabajamos un
montón una de nuestras propuestas es
construir nano guardias de tráfico que
regulen ese paso de fotones con
nanopartículas nanopartículas de un
material que cambia sus propiedades
ópticas cuando vayamos un poquito la
temperatura o la presión de manera que
activando en distintas partes del
circuito nuestras manos partículas o
nano agentes de tráfico podemos regular
el paso de los fotones y así codificar
la luz
la nanofotónica tiene hoy en día ya
muchas aplicaciones
en muchos campos y os voy a contar unas
poquitas por ejemplo como
interconexiones en servidores de
empresas tan conocidas como facebook
amazon o ibm
para seguridad en aeropuertos hemos
desarrollado sensores ultra sensibles
que son capaces de detectar pequeñísimas
partículas de tnt que podrían estar
integrados en los uniformes de nuestros
agentes o en drones o robots pero la más
extraordinaria y la más sorprendente en
biomedicina
mirad hemos desarrollado unas antenas
que son capaces de detectar cantidades
pequeñísimas de adn o de bacterias como
la legionela mucho antes de que se
produzca una contaminación masiva o
también otros dispositivos para la
detección temprana de enfermedades como
el cáncer que funcionan con una sola
gota de sangre que son portátiles y de
bajo coste rápidos fáciles de usar
fiables podrían llegar muy pronto a
nuestros centros de salud y a países en
vías de desarrollo
y la nanofotónica también será la
responsable de muchas de las tecnologías
del futuro por ejemplo regulará el
tráfico de esos coches autónomos de las
ciudades del futuro o también será la
responsable de hacer las memorias de los
futuros ordenadores cuánticos
el límite solo está en nuestra
imaginación
nunca soñar en pequeño se había
convertido en algo tan grande muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero no